what a night it was in the women's
weightlifting here in tokyo last night
and as you say a first gb medal for
women's weightlifting and i'm delighted
to say that emily campbell who won that
medal
is with us here in tokyo on the rooftop
of the gb base
emily how are you feeling that was just
such a intense night for women's
weightlifting last night
yeah no definitely i mean it's you know
essentially history making and
i was just so glad to be a part of it
you know those girls have came out and
you know performed out of our skin you
know
all top eight finishes and then
obviously to top it off with a medal is
is fantastic and
yeah i'm just over the moon i'm really
happy with the way the performance went
it
you know it didn't all go to plan but
you know that's the way that sport is
um but you know it's the result that
always counts just lift that medal up
for us and
tell us what that means because you're
not lottery funded you've had to kind of
get to tokyo the hard way and the people
of nottingham have helped you
to get here aren't they oh yeah this
means everything and this is definitely
a lot sweeter knowing that you know
all the trials and tribulations you had
to go through to get to get where i am
today and i'm just
so thankful for every single person
that's been a part of my journey you
know
a lot of my support staff that i work
with you know work with me on a
sponsored basis or work with me for free
um you know so my nutritionist my
physiotherapist
all of that you know without them guys i
would not be where i am today and then
you know down to the bags of fruit i get
off the market and the cobbler's sorting
out my boots you know
every single person contributed to me
getting this last night and you know i
couldn't can never
ever repay you all we saw of course in
your weightlifting final last night
laurel hubbard as well the new zealand
weightlifter the first trans
individual competitor in the olympic
games what is your
thought this morning on just what she
has done for women's weightlifting
i mean it's brought a lot of attention
to the sport and i hope that now people
come back to the sport and just watch it
because they love weightlifting
and i hope that i put on a good enough
show last night to show that you know
people x weightlifting is exciting and
it's great to watch and it's really
intense and it brings you a
rollercoaster of emotions
and you know if girls and boys out there
watch that last night and want to pick
up a barbell please go and do it there's
ways of doing it
hit the british weightlifting website
we'd love to have you all and the more
lifters we can get the better so
thank you and final thought emily i know
that you've said previously that you've
been doing this
to show what plus size women can do in
sport and how important that is tell me
about
what you see as uh as what you achieved
last night
in that respect yeah definitely i mean
you know i don't like a typical athlete
i don't have the typical athlete body
but you know what my body does is
amazing so
you know i want to prove that it doesn't
matter what you look like what's as you
are how much you weigh
you know if you want to achieve
something in sport if you put your mind
to it you can and i hope that i proved
that last night
emily campbell silver medalist
congratulations thank you so much for
talking to us live